monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
mesdames et messieurs pris dans les
rapporteurs merci chers collègues ce
texte au fond nous pose un problème de
naissance il est mal née il est mal née
et j'en veux pour preuve la façon dont
s'est déroulé le débat à l'assemblée
nationale
ce n'est pas un texte de réponse à la
vague actuelle notre à porter a raison
sur ce point là comme sur d'autres
d'ailleurs
et pourtant le gouvernement a tenté de
passer en force jusqu à s'offusquer que
les députés ne veuille pas délibéré à 4
heures du matin
et bien c'est compliqué politiquement
et pourtant vous savez que nous ne
sommes pas irresponsables en termes de
gestion de la crise sanitaire
d'approuver un texte qui à ce point est
une posture politique
il y avait la possibilité
monsieur le ministre de revenir devant
le parlement comme nous vous l'avions
proposé en janvier février pour faire un
point sur la situation vous ne vouliez
pas
à la fin de l'année dernière constatant
que l'épidémie devenait hors de contrôle
et que dans les écoles notamment vous
avez délibérément laissé circuler le
virus nous ne cesserons de rappeler que
le ministre de l'éducation a allégé le
protocole quand le nombre de classes
fermées augmenter et bien la situation à
échapper totalement avec le variant au
micro au certes il aurait circulé
personne aucun pays n'échappera vario
micro main pic d'une telle intensité
nous pouvions y échapper
alors vous venez avec ce texte qui a un
autre défaut c'est que certes il faut
s'adapter mais il faut aussi que la loi
elle se projette dans la durée et
légiférer dans la durée c'est dire à nos
compatriotes que certes peut-être le
scénario optimisme seul ministre mais
qu' il faudrait mieux prévoir le
maintien d'une protection collective
élevé dans la durée pour notre
population et pour ça nous nous vous
proposons une méthode l'adoption d'un
principe sans le déguiser l'obligation
vaccinale universel parce que ça
rassemble parce que ça ne clique pas les
français entre eux parce qu'on ne dit
pas que tel fait sion doit les gendarmes
et l autre ne doit pas les policiers
parce que nous signifions ainsi et c'est
le rôle de la politique que tous
ensemble nous faisons face à cette
épidémie que nous devons tous la
protection aux soignants de notre pays à
notre système de santé et les uns aux
autres et puis après on voit les
modalités d'application et on ne posera
pas convaincre et contraindre c'est un
piège oui il ya une part de contraintes
et le pass vaccinale ou le certificat de
vaccination on l'appellera comme on veut
peut-être un des outils de contrôle nous
ne l'excluons pas nous en discuterons
les modalités mais dans un cadre bien
posé bien née et puis à le convaincre
bien sûr que personne auxquelles
personne ne veut renoncer et ceux qui
répètent que on ne mène pas assez ce
travail d'aller vers ont également
raison et bien si ce cadre était ainsi
posée nous pourrions débattre et
légiférer sereinement et non pas pour
les quinze jours à venir et encore une
fois sans efficience mais de façon
beaucoup plus durable alors voilà notre
position elle est simple elle est claire
elle a toujours été la même c'est dans
ce cadre que nous étudierons ce texte
que nous tenterons d'y apporter comme
l'a dit mon collègue jean pierre sueur
les améliorations qui sont
indispensables pour qu'on puisse le
voter etc ainsi nous respecterons les
français jouent bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]